Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
Marvel has revealed more cameos
during Deadpool 3.
In addition to Wolverine
and most of the X-Men coming back.
And it's Chris Evans confirming
a bunch of theories that we all had.
So we'll break it all down.
They're still in the middle
of filming the movie,
so we'll be getting more footage
in detail soon.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'm also in the middle of Secret invasion
episodes, but that won't be quite
as connected to Deadpool three
as some of the other Marvel movies.
There are a couple of major story arcs
that run across Marvel Phase five and six
leading into Avengers
five, all the Deadpool three stuff
is more connected to what's happening
with Kang in the Multiverse War.
All the incursions,
that's why they're basically
doing a version of Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe, but it's more like
Deadpool kills the Fox Marvel Universe
Just because that's where most of these
cameo scenes are coming from, from the Fox
Marvel movies, the big news
you probably saw in your feeds recently
is that one of the confirmed
major cameos is Chris Evans
coming back as his Human torch
from the Fantastic Four.
And he even talked
about doing this a while ago.
So a lot of people assumed
that he would be in the movie, I mean,
I don't exactly look the same anymore.
I was 15, almost 20 years ago. Got old,
but I really love that character.
Yeah. Look, I,
I would love it with nothing.
That would actually be an easier
sell to me than coming back is cap.
You know what I mean?
Cap is so precious to me.
And, you know,
I almost don't want to disrupt
what a beautiful experience that was.
But Johnny Storm,
I feel like he didn't really get his day.
That was before
Marvel really found its footing.
So I love that role.
And, you know, who knows?
even though it seems like
he doesn't want to come back
as his version of Steve Rogers.
Captain America in the MCU movies,
it's important to note that he didn't say
he'd never come back as Steve Rogers,
just that he didn't want to come back
as the character right away.
Like right after Avengers Endgame,
he wanted to give us some time to breathe.
but it's been almost 17 years since
Fantastic Four Rise of the Silver Surfer.
That's why he's totally cool.
Coming back as Human Torch,
or at least is his version of Human Torch.
he literally just did a cameo scene
in Ryan Reynolds
free Guy movie for a Captain America joke.
So that explains the connection
between the two of them.
Like, oh,
he probably just asked them to come back
for Deadpool three right after that.
another ton of
questions about which version of Human
Torch is going to be.
A lot of the versions
of these cameo scenes
won't be from the main X-Men
or universe versions of the characters.
It'll just be the actors coming back
playing different variants
of the characters.
In most cases.
But for those you asking about where
all those Fox Marvel movies took place,
at which universe did those come from?
A while ago, the writers of the X-Men
First Class movie revealed
that Fox had them write their own
Fox Universe version of a marvel Civil
War movie crossover with the fantastic
Four versus the X-Men.
Had they continued developing the movie
that would have come out
around the same time. X-Men
Days of Future Past came out.
but during Days of Future Past,
they confirmed that the original X-Men
movies took place in the same universe
as the first class movies.
Just later in the timeline.
So that means the Fantastic Four movies
would have been also in that same universe
because they were planning on doing
a big crossover with all those characters.
so it basically confirms
that all of the Fox Marvel movies
took place in the same universe,
even the ones in the early 2000.
Now, there were some jokes about this
during Deadpool two Post-Credits scene
where Deadpool goes into the Wolverine
Origins movie to kill the other
Deadpool version of himself.
So the way they explain
that is kind of like the Loki explainer,
where some timelines are very similar
But slightly different.
When you talk about alternate universe,
it's like when does an alternate timeline
become an alternate universe?
That's usually
when things are radically different.
wound up happening with that Fantastic
Four versus X-Men movie?
Is that Bryan Singer came back to do
Days of Future Past like they decided
to do Days of Future Past
instead of the Fantastic
Four versus X-Men movie.
so the studio just scrapped the idea
but had Disney not bought Fox
and things had continued on
in that X-Men timeline with the Fox movies
they might have eventually done
a fantastic four crossover movie
But in the short term, they just chose
to continue with that X-Men timeline.
We got X-Men Apocalypse, Dark, Phenix,
then Disney bought Fox.
All that went down.
They got the characters back.
Now they're doing new versions of all
those characters in totally new movies.
But before they do that,
they're using Deadpool three as a
no way home type of movie.
For all of the Fox
Marvel characters coming back.
some of them also come back
during Avengers six Secret Wars,
but they're giving all of them
a big swansong
before recasting most of those roles.
like we're not a racing.
All of your movies, you're all still kin
and you just come
from different universes.
Or in the case of the Fox Marvel movies,
the same universe.
most of the plot of Deadpool
three revolves around a house of M
universe that Deadpool travels to, where
the X-Men and the mutants reign supreme.
Magneto takes over the planet in Marvel
hasn't said which part of the movie
Chris Evans Human Torch would appear in
There are a couple points in the movie
where they pay off the end of Deadpool two
with cable's time travel device where he's
hopping around different timelines.
Chris Evans Cameos in
could come during one of those
when he's just hopping across
different timelines.
It might wind up
being a smaller cameo scene.
Kind of like his free guy
cameo seemed like really quick blink
and you'll miss that,
where he just appears for
a second is Deadpool is running across
those different timelines.
most of the movie,
though, is meant to be kind of like
Deadpool kills the Fox Marvel Universe.
Most of the craziness
will happen in the House of M Universe
that he travels to during
that part of the movie near the climax.
I believe they're supposed
to get really crazy with the cameos in
in a bunch of variants
of the same characters will be on screen
together in a big battle like multiple
versions of Wolverine, multiple versions
of Deadpool and others together on screen.
Imagine a much better version of what
they did with that concept in Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania with all
the different Ant-Man together on screen,
but just a bunch of Deadpool's Wolverine
and maybe a couple other characters.
the funny thing about this Hugh Jackman
kind of spoiled the idea a while ago
when he revealed he'd be playing multiple
versions of Wolverine during the movie,
not just a single version of Wolverine,
because, you know, it's science and
and so I don't
have to agree with the Logan timeline,
which was important to me
and I think probably to the fans
All because of this device
they have in the Marvel world
of moving around timelines.
Now we can go back Hugh Jackman
trying to join the Spoiler bros.
Tom Hall was also joking about this
too, recently,
where he tried to say
that he was giving away fewer spoilers
than anyone else
on the last Spider-Man movie No Way Home.
like he is now really good
about not giving away spoilers
compared to everyone else.
for those of you that are waiting to see
Chris Evans come back in the MCU as his.
Steve Rogers I think there will be some
references to him in Captain America four.
It'd be weird if there weren't
what really happened to old man cap?
Just a pay out that moon base theory
scene from Falcon Winter Soldier.
we also might see Chris Evans come back
during Avengers
six as another alternate reality
version of Captain America
be they're going to base
some of those movies on Avengers forever.
And during that storyline,
Kang actually gets an evil version
of The Avengers from an alternate reality
to fight the Good Avengers.
that would be really cool to bring back
some of the original Avengers
who have died, like for instance,
Iron Man, Captain America
as alternate reality versions
that are fighting the main Avengers.
everyone's going to be clamoring
for Elizabeth Olsen to have some kind of
cameo in Scarlet Witch just because of her
relationship with Magneto in the comics.
Because a long time ago, Elizabeth Olsen
did say that when they pay off Magneto
being Scarlet Witch is true
father in the movies,
she wanted it to be
a version of Ian McKellen's
Magneto instead of Michael Fassbender,
based on their ages.
It would also just make more sense
if you bring the older version of Magneto
for something like that,
Oh, I'm going to go with Sir Ian McKellen.
even though technically
because of all the timeline craziness
now and days of future past,
Michael Fassbender is now canonically
the younger version
of Ian McKellen's Magneto.
So technically they play
the exact same version of the character
and when I say House of M Plot,
supposedly the timeline
Deadpool meets Wolverine is inspired
by the events of House of M,
if you didn't read that comic book
storyline, that's one of the most
famous X-Men storylines,
one of the most famous Scarlet
Witch storylines where Magneto
in all mutants reigns supreme
over the world, who most superior
compared to Homo sapiens.
Magneto
basically takes over the entire planet
in that storyline, using Scarlet Witch's
reality warping powers like MCU,
Scarlet Witch,
creating a massive hex around the world.
there were so many theories
about this during Wandavision
because it almost wound up happening
like the boundaries of the hex
during the show
kept expanding throughout the episodes.
Eventually it would have covered most
of the planet, altering everyone inside
who wasn't powerful enough
to withstand her chaos.
Magic.
they're only a couple of people
in the Marvel Universe
that are powerful enough to do that.
Like her chaos
Magic wouldn't work on the higher level
Cosmic entities or the Celestials.
The Celestials were also immune
to the effects of the snap.
That's how powerful they're meant to be.
But. In Deadpool three, the rumor
is that in the alternate universe.
Professor X in the X-Men
originally wound up siding
with Magneto in the Brotherhood of Mutants
instead of fighting against them.
during the events of the first X-Men
movie, remember, during the events of that
movie, Magneto was trying to forcibly
mutate a giant portion of the world.
So the majority of the population
would be mutants, and they would reign
supreme over regular humans.
during the movie, Deadpool
supposedly winds up trying to win
over that universe's version of Wolverine,
played by Hugh Jackman, of course.
And he'll have a version
of the yellow costume from the comics.
that also makes
it sound like those other X-Men
that are coming
back will wear much more comic book
accurate costumes
like the ones from X-Men Apocalypse Two.
That would actually be pretty cool.
it ultimately it's that universe
that Deadpool winds up
causing the destruction of it.
Kevin Feige He also said that in addition
to that, just like within the scope
of Marvel Phase six, Deadpool
three would be a big tipping point.
With the incursion
storyline leading up to Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars.
a bunch of universes being destroyed.
And it sounds like Deadpool
does something so crazy that it winds up
causing a bunch of incursions
in tons of universes get destroyed.
Not just that one.
And that'll pay off.
The Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe.
Part of the storyline
that they're also adapting
so it's kind of like they're combining
the Loki storyline with the TVA
with a version of House of them
and Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe,
But this is just the beginning
for Deadpool three and all those cameos.
We've already found out
about a few other people
that are coming back in that movie.
So I'll do a new video for them soon.
Let me know in the comments.
Which other characters do you want to see?
Come back in Deadpool three.
my poll Secret Invasion Episode
three video
We'll post next Make sure to enable alerts
from my channel so you don't miss that.
Click here for that video,
Update the link as soon as I post that
and click here for that new Fantastic
Four Dr.
Doom video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe in maximum effort!